a water tank is 12 feet high 5 feet long
and 9 feet wide a solid metal box which
is 7 feet high 4 feet long and 8 feet
wide is sitting at the bottom of the
tank the tank is filled with water what
is the volume of the water in the tank
so let's think about this we have a
water tank it's 12 feet high try to draw
this as good as I can so it's 12 feet
high it's 5 feet long so this looks like
that's about 5 feet and it's 9 feet wide
so this is my best rendition of what the
tank looks like so the tank might look
something like this that is my water
tank let me draw it draw the whole thing
so there's my water tank and I'm gonna
make it transparent so that we can see
what's going on inside of the tank so
here we go just like a helicopter
outside or something I don't know if
y'all hear that but let's see so there
is my water tank 12 feet high 12 feet
high 5 feet long and 9 feet wide 9 foot
wide and then they say there's a solid
metal box which is 7 feet high 4 feet
long and 8 feet wide sitting at the
bottom sitting at the bottom so let's
see if I can draw that
so let's it's 4 feet wide 4 feet or I
guess we could say 4 feet long 7 feet
high so see 4 feet might look something
like this it's 7 feet high which might
look something like that 7 feet high
obviously I'm not drawing it perfectly
to scale 7 feet high and 8 feet wide so
it might look something something like
this as it's sitting in this tank so
this is that metal box and I'll just
it's and they say it's a solid metal box
it's not like any water can fit in here
so let me make it as a solid metal box
so this is a solid metal box and then
I'm gonna fill the whole thing I'm gonna
fill the whole thing with water I'm
gonna pour water into this thing and the
water is gonna start filling up and it's
gonna fill up all the volume of the tank
except except where the metal box is
it's not gonna be able to fill in that
volume because the metal box
the metal box is solid it's gonna fill
up we're gonna fill it slowly fill this
thing up around the metal box so what's
the volume that's gonna fill up well
it's gonna fill up the volume of the
tank minus the volume of the metal box
it couldn't fill in the metal box volume
so let's figure out what that is the
volume of the tank is going to be nine
foot by five foot times twelve feet
that's the volume of the tank tank
volume tank volume and from that we want
to subtract the metal box volume so
minus four foot by eight feet by eight
feet 8 feet by 7 feet by 7 feet by 7
feet this is 4 feet wide it is 8 feet
what do they see it's 7 feet high 7 feet
high it's 4 feet long and it's 8 feet
wide 8 feet wide so this right over here
is the volume this is the I guess we
could call it the metal box volume the
box volume and so what's in between or
when you take the tank volume subtract
out the box volume that's how much the
water can actually fill in so I only do
the water partially filled but once it's
already filled in the water is going to
go all the way to the top here and it
will fill in everything except for where
that blue box is so what's to figure out
this value value is so 5 times 12 is 60
60 times 9 is 540 and then in blue here
let's see 4 times 8 is 32 32 times 7 is
210 plus 14 which is 224 so it's minus 2
24 minus to 2048 I do that right I don't
make a careless mistake so 32 times 7 2
times 7 is 14 3 which is really a 30
here 30 times 7 is 210 plus another 10
is 220 so 224 so this is going to be
equal to let's see 500 minus 200 is 300
300 and then 40 minus 25
or is 16 316 and our units are in cubic
feet so the volume of the water to tank
316 cubic feet